hey guys Ryan right here hi guys I'm
Veronica six DOS so the legacy continues
with the trailer releases of Mortal
Kombat X and the journey of Veronica six
toasts learning to become immune to such
violence so she can become a warrior one
day continues I might be more tolerant
this time you might be more tolerant
this time who knows I'm like I've grown
like this much he nice
that's the same sizes as your penis
that's my penis this thing you would
know Kage family trailer blood and gore
intent with its true language but some
it is difficult to rise to stand above
the rest to conquer as a true rear but
not for those who share the bloodlines
of Champions
ready dazzle
you're updating kawaii
he said why are you bothering me and I
said because my ex-wife is a pain
ah
transfer 120 oh now she trusts me makes
it well if they don't kill us
you
Oh
still not am you in are you no no no
[ __ ] way no [ __ ] ways I hope I am
never immune to that [ __ ] those [ __ ]
nut I can't wait to play that game it
looks like so much fun
wait Veronica I have a question why did
you think that would be the only Mortal
Kombat video we would watch today I
don't know what this is someone just let
me to watch it imagine anything being
worsen well this isn't way to the last
one that we saw is the worst of all the
ones in flashed well this is only 24
seconds and it says Jason Voorhees
reveal trailer that's the dude from
Friday the 13th okay I hope we see some
of this the grey trailer is in mortal
combat no um I guess a bonus character
or this is a prank
you guys tell us I'm so glad I didn't
you just a solo video for that yeah that
would have been a waste of everyone's
time I was like less than ten play and
nothing happened oh and are the other
reactors reacted yeah probably like we
should get on a conference call and
discuss how we all reacted to know like
find out like what's going on in the
reactor world you know we all work
together no totally except Iroh Magnus
thinks he's like Superman and has
nothing to do with us like he's just out
in his own world they not yeah I don't
tell you the secret weapon the one who's
gonna change everything for us for
eternity gator Martin Gator yeah one day
I predict Gator Martin is gonna rise to
the top and him and Tyrone are gonna
have a fight one tall giant black man
versus one decently hided Oh smaller
black skinny man they're gonna fight
they're gonna fight they're gonna work
together they're gonna have a react off
anyway guys use the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects Veronica
has a music and vlog channel if you love
her personality you got to go to the
vlogging you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter fit another acronym
l.o.v.e l for lickin lips o for oh yeah
V for oh you lucky like a vacuum cleaner
what I mean vagina
come on too obvious e for let's take
some ecstasy to and heighten this
experience anyway guys this is the key
to a true relationship enjoy yourselves
tonight